[Music]
so john it's been at least
six to nine months since i've really
pissed somebody off about covid
so um i'm way over
i'm way overdue oh good but um i'll
tread as gently as i can uh we're
talking at the break and we're talking
about bridgette and
the
what was the low point for her was the
summer of 2020 when her company's laying
people off being furloughed she didn't
know if she's going to lose her 100 plus
thousand dollar a year job instead she
ends up getting a promotion so it nets
out
we've got
uh
this company with 1200 team members the
leadership team here is scratching and
clawing and entire segments of our
revenue just evaporated and we've got
the responsibility to these 1200
families that we promised them we were
going to pay them and the stress of our
on our leadership team of carrying that
um
and uh my friend craig groeschel just
did a podcast um later she does a
leadership podcast i was on it a little
while back i'm getting ready to be on
another one but he just did want to
listen to this week he talked about how
people were depleted
and that we need to
as we lead out of
this pandemic we need to be replenished
we need to be refilled
filled back up our gas tank is empty the
gr gears are grinding there's no oil in
the crank case there's no lubricant in
our lives anymore we got nothing left
and in the middle of that the economy
goes bonkers
with inflation and with job
opportunities there's labor wars so
people are fighting over you to pay you
more but they want to work you more
than you've ever worked in your life in
order for to get that pay
and so we went from
scared to death trapped at home
sitting on zero to
220 miles an hour
with no lubrication in the engine that's
right and so we've got a whole bunch of
people out there that are completely
depleted
and um
they're gonna smoke
it's gonna the engine's gonna smoke it's
gonna blow yeah and if you if you back
out and say you know our friend jaco
talks about this there's been no
ownership of
the good or the bad
you can't
you have to acknowledge what happened to
you negatively yeah it became
politicized as to whether they were
right or not to do the quarantine right
or not to do so
right or not to make me clean the office
of 60 000 bucks a swipe by the cdc
guidelines and then they come out later
and say it doesn't help at all right
after i spent 250 000 cleaning the
freaking office of people back at work
and people still
sending us hate mail and bomb threats
that's right in the building
it's because we dared to be at work when
you when you experience a collective
trauma somebody has to stop
everybody and say well before we race
off and before we move on before we
start print money and pretend this never
happened which is what we've done right
and bridgette talked about she went
through a divorce she had some loss and
so she just i'm just going to open a
yoga studio yeah right because i'm just
going to pretend this and then that ends
in ash and all of us who have launched
out of the last six months trying to
pretend the last two years never
happened and not collectively grieve
what we lost we a million people and we
lost people are dead our friends our
family members passed away we've looked
back and said we shouldn't have done it
like this will someone just say that
please and we should have been all that
has to ha you have to process that
together you have to otherwise you take
off you got no i love that you said
there's no oil on the in the in the
engine it'll go for another 150 miles
200 miles and you're gonna be all the
people can be straight on the side of
the road man i hate it own it man stop
and own what happened so that you could
move forward yeah well societally we're
not gonna get anyone to own it at
leadership because we don't have any
leaders it's so embarrassing man and so
embarrassing societally they're not
gonna own it what what jocko says that a
good leader should do is not gonna
happen
so given that that's not gonna happen
um each of us as individuals have got to
own
our part of it and go oh wait a minute
that did happen to me
that did hurt
i was
terrorized
by my own government
by people who disagreed with me yeah
and if you believed one thing the other
side terrorized you it didn't matter
what it was you believed right because
the source of truth was no longer there
was no source of truth
um anybody that claimed to be the source
of truth was laughed at um because uh
because they weren't the source of truth
you know uh eg fauci you know and so uh
you know has become a laughing you know
it's become a laughing stock
of the whole thing he's like the he was
like the head of the circus yeah you
know and so but nobody's coming back and
going look he was just wrong yeah
two million people he never slayed he
never came up and said hey last three
months i said this i was inaccurate we
got new data it's time to do this now no
that never happened never once and if if
if i could pass along one piece of
information after working with hurting
people for so many years and you too
if you're in leadership and you head
down a road and you realize this isn't
the right road just stop and turn back
to tell the folks keep your we're on the
wrong road keep your reverse gear in
good working order
that's such a gift to everybody and it's
not a matter of of weakness or failure
it's a matter of strength right just to
say hey we got new data and it's time to
do this now and i had said this let's
but all of us i think you're right i we
can talk about that all day
what i have to do is look in the mirror
me and my wife have had to have so you
can
we're not going to fix those goobers
okay but what you and i do need to you
address for the listener right this
second is
that
um you can't go on as if nothing
happened that's right because it did
denial is not a river in egypt that's
right it's a real thing
and so you have got to
uh say this happened
i i
face stuff i've never faced before i've
felt things i never felt before i may
have even done things or done before and
and
uh
i'm
i'm not gonna go back to the way it was
until i put some gas back in my tank and
then it'll never really be back the way
i to build something new that's right
i'm going to lead not
as if nothing happened i'm going to lead
out of this i'm going to leave my life
and you are in control of leading your
life if you're listening to us right now
so lead your own life you know leading
your life is you are the leader and so
you have to use critical thinking skills
you have to say
emotionally this hurt physically i was
scared for my life
um there was you know trauma with that
and the real world is that that really
happened now is it debilitating for the
rest of your life does it have to become
the defining thing for your life
absolutely not it shouldn't be but if
you pretend like it didn't happen you're
going to turn to ash
everything around you will turn to ashes
right one of the most
common questions i get is where i start
and i would say 95 of the time
there's a relationship or two that was
significant to you that went away over
the last couple of years either they
said something you said something you
felt the way they felt the way and
that's where i would start i would look
over the course of the relationships
that i burned or lost or got frustrated
with over the last couple of years and
say is there some people in there i need
to call and say dude 30 years isn't
worth this over the last two years let's
is there a conversation i need to have
with my spouse and say hey man we got
sideways the last two years and i just
put some stuff in in the drawer we need
to just have a chit chat but are there
relationships that i can begin to heal
and maybe there aren't maybe i need to
then replace those that are gone yeah or
it might just be you say okay i don't
respect that person that's right so
we've moved on but i've got to replace
those with other people in my life right
yeah this person uh i
i saw new colors and i saw things about
them that i don't wanna i don't wanna be
around that's right but i can't i can't
use that as an excuse to do life by
myself anymore right i got to go find
new people that doesn't give you excuse
to not deal with you that's right